♪ ♪
>> Greg: ACCORDING TO THE
MUELLER INDICTMENT AFTER THE
2016 ELECTION, RUSSIANS
ORGANIZED ANTI-TRUMP RALLIES
WHICH WERE BREATHLESSLY COVERED
BY HOPEFUL CNN AND MSNBC.
>> MORGAN IS THAT UNION SQUARE
IN NEW YORK CITY.
>> I WANT TO SHOW YOU SOME OF
THE SIGNS AND POSTERS THEY ARE
HOLDING UP.
YOU CAN SEE ONE THAT SAYS
TEACHERS AGAINST TRUMP.
>> ARE NOT GOING TO BE
TOLERATING SEXISM OR HOMOPHOBIA.
>> THIS IS SOMETHING DIFFERENT.
THE ENERGY HERE IS ELECTRIC.
>> THERE ARE THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
TAKING OVER FIFTH AVENUE WITH
SEVERAL MESSAGES, ALL AIMED AT
THE PRESIDENT-ELECT.
IT'S THE MOST ORGANIZED PROTESTS
I'VE SEEN HAPPEN HERE IN
NEW YORK CITY.
>> Greg: BECAUSE IT'S
ORGANIZED BY RUSSIANS.
OKAY.
WE RAN A SHORT CLIP OF THE SHORT
PROTEST BUT AT LEAST WE SHOWED
SOME RESTRAINT.
RUSSIA WAS ABLE TO YANK
AMERICA'S CHAIN BY THINKING AT
OUR OWN EXISTING TEAM SPORT
MENTALITY.
THEY DON'T NEED TO ORGANIZE
THESE RALLIES.
WE HATED EACH OTHER ALREADY.
WHEN ONE ANGRY GROUP WON'T
ACCEPT AN ELECTION CAN HELP WITH
THE RUSSIANS RESIST?
THEY SPREAD RUMORS TO UNDERMINE
ALL SIDES IN THE MEDIA OF COURSE
AS YOU CAN TELL LAUGHS IT OUT.
DON'T TRUST THE RUSSIANS.
EVERY CONSERVATIVE AWAKE IN THE
1970s KNEW THIS.
THAT'S WHAT KILLS ME ABOUT THE
LEFT.
RUSSIA IS A FRACTION OF WHAT
THEY WERE DURING THE COLD WAR
AND NOW THE DEMOCRATS ARE
WORRIED?
DECADES AGO WHEN THE RIGHT TO
CHALLENGE THE USSR, THE LEFT
AIDED THE SOVIETS, LEADING THE
ANTI-ANTI-COMMUNIST CHARGE.
MEANWHILE COMMUNIST INFLUENCE
HELPED REPEL AMERICAN PROTESTS
AND RALLIES BACKING EVERY
LEFT-WING CAUSE, CHARMING EVERY
DUMB CELEBRITY ON THE LEFT.
THEY DIDN'T MIND AT ALL.
BETTER TO BE ON JOE STALIN'S
SIDE THAN JOE McCARTHY.
NOW THEY ARE MAD ABOUT THE
RUSSIANS.
SCREW THEM.
THEY ARE LIKE THE GUY WHO OFFERS
TO HELP YOU MOVE WHAT SHOWS UP
WHEN IT'S DONE IN THE PIZZA HAS
ARRIVED.
WE DON'T NEED YOU ANYMORE.
ALL OF THE HEAVY LIFTING HAS
BEEN DONE.
>> Kimberly: I HATE WHEN THAT
HAPPENS.
>> Greg: YOU HAVE PROFESSIONAL
MOVERS, KIMBERLY.
>> Kimberly: HALF OF MY STUFF
ENDS UP MISSING.
>> Greg: DANA, I HAVE A
THEORY.
IN MY MIND, WHAT CHANGED AMERICA
PERMANENTLY WAS THE VIETNAM WAR.
AND ACCORDING TO A RUSSIAN
DEFECTOR, THE SOVIET UNION GAVE
$100 BILLION TO AMERICAN ANTIWAR
MOVEMENTS.
THAT -- WE WORK THAT SPLIT.
OUR COUNTRY WASN'T SPLIT UNTIL
THEN.
THEY INFUSED A BILLION DOLLARS
INTO THE ANTIWAR MOVEMENT INTO A
LOT OF OTHER PEACE MOVEMENTS.
THEY HAVE SO MANY SHADOW
ORGANIZATIONS.
WE SPLIT.
THROUGH THE '70s, IT
CONTINUED.
WE NEVER, EVER CAME BACK.
WE NEVER HEALED.
I BELIEVE THE RUSSIANS, USSR,
BIGGEST VICTORY THEY'VE HAD WAS
CREATING THE DIVISION DURING THE
VIETNAM WAR.
THE STUFF WE ARE SEEING, THE
MEDIA ATE IT UP.
THAT IS NOTHING COMPARED TO WHAT
WE'VE BEEN THROUGH FOR 50 YEARS.
>> Dana: THAT'S A GREAT
THEORY.
YOU KNOW WHO IS DOING THAT NOW
IN A DIFFERENT WAY?
CHINA.
THESE CONFUCIUS CENTERS THEY
HAVE AT UNIVERSITIES ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
THERE ARE SOME UNIVERSITY
STARTING TO REJECT IT BUT THAT'S
HAPPENING.
ON THE MEDIA SITE, IT WAS A VERY
DIFFERENT STORY IN FRANCE.
LAST YEAR THEY HAD AN ELECTION
AS WELL.
EMMANUEL MACRON ORDERED THE
MEDIA -- I'M SORRY THE ELECTORAL
COMMISSION, NOT TO COVER THE
LEAKED EMAILS.
THEY COULD BE PROSECUTED.
THAT WOULD NEVER HAPPEN HERE
BECAUSE WE HAVE A
FIRST AMENDMENT.
IT WAS A VERY DIFFERENT STORY
THERE.
THEY WERE ABLE TO BLOCK RUSSIA
FROM DOING IT BECAUSE THEY WERE
ABLE TO BAND TOGETHER IN SAME WE
ARE GOING TO PUT FRANCE FIRST.
THAT'S WHAT ENDED UP HAPPENING.
THE MEDIA HAS SOME COMPLICITY
UNWITTING POSSIBLY.
IN SOWING THE CHAOS.
I WOULD LIKE YOUR THEORY.
>> Greg: JUAN, YOU ARE
SLIGHTLY OLDER THAN ME.
DO YOU REMEMBER HOW
CONSERVATIVES AND THE '70s
WERE MARKED ABOUT A RUSSIAN
UNDER EVERY BED.
IT WAS CONSIDERED HYSTERIA.
FUNDAMENTALLY WE WERE RIGHT ALL
ALONG ABOUT THE RUSSIAN
INFLUENCE.
AT LEAST ON CAMPUSES AND IN
THESE ANTIWAR MOVEMENTS.
CORRECT?
>> Juan: I DON'T REMEMBER IT
THAT WAY.
READING BACK, WHAT YOU CITED,
JOE McCARTHY VERY REAL AND
TRAUMATIZING FOR THE AMERICAN
BODY POLITIC IN THE '50s THAT
SOME WOULD BE IDENTIFYING,
BLACKLISTING PEOPLE, LABELING
THEM AS HAVING COMMUNIST
ASSOCIATIONS.
THE CIVIL RIGHTS MOVEMENT,
DR. KING, HIS ASSOCIATES.
>> Greg: YOU TAKE PEOPLE WHO
ARE ANTI-COMMUNIST AND PLACE IT
IN THE SAME LUMP IS JOE
McCARTHY.
>> Juan: NO, I THINK WHAT YOU
HAVE TO DO IS WHEN YOU SAY
PEOPLE ARE ANTI-COMMUNIST, YOU
HAVE TO TAKE THEM SERIOUSLY.
I THINK MOST AMERICANS ARE
ANTI-COMMUNIST.
>> Greg: THE LEFT WAS
ANTI-ANTI-COMMUNIST.
>> Juan: THEY WERE SAYING IF
YOU GO TO EXTREMES, YOU'RE GOING
TO DAMAGE PEOPLE'S LIVES AND
CAREERS THROUGH INNUENDO AND
SMEARING THEM.
MY FEELING IS, ON THIS ONE, I
READ MICHAEL MOORE WAS AT THE
PROTEST YOU SHOWED US.
MY FEELING IS YOU GET THIS IN
THE AFTERMATH OF THE
OVERWHELMING EFFORT BY THE
RUSSIANS TO SOW DISCONTENT,
DISCORD, TO APPEAL TO ONE SIDE
OR ANOTHER.
TRUMP WINS THE ELECTION.
NOW THEY ARE GOING TO FORCE THE
ANTI-TRUMP -- ALL THEY WANT IS
TO DESTABILIZE US, LOSE TRUST IN
OUR INSTITUTIONS, LOSE TRUST ALL
AROUND.
WHY ISN'T TRUMP DOING ANYTHING
NOW?
>> Greg: NOW YOU'RE JUST
PLAYING INTO IT BY SAYING WHY
ISN'T TRUMP DOING X?
>> Juan: YOUR THING ABOUT THE
PRESS IS WILDER TO ME.
IF THE PRESS DIDN'T COVER ALL
THOSE LEAKED EMAILS, YOU
WOULD'VE SAID THEY ARE COVERING
FOR HILLARY.
>> Greg: I DON'T KNOW ABOUT
THAT.
>> Kimberly: THE THING HERE IS
RUSSIA HAS BEEN DOING THIS
FOREVER.
THIS IS WHAT THEY'VE BEEN DOING.
IT'S NOTHING NEW.
THIS IS SOMETHING -- THIS ISN'T
SOMETHING THEY CAME UP WITH LAST
YEAR TO TRY TO CREATE CHAOS IN
AMERICAN POLITICS.
THEY THRIVE ON DISINFORMATION
CAMPAIGNS.
THEY PICKED ONE SIDE AGAINST
EACH OTHER AND FLIPPED TO THE
OTHER SIDE.
THEY HAVE NO LOYALTY.
THEY BEAR NO ALLEGIANCE EXCEPT
TO THEIR OWN CAUSE.
TODAY THEY GO FOR BROKE TRUMP.
TOMORROW THEY GO ANTI-TRUMP.
THEY WANT EVERYTHING IN TOTAL
DISARRAY.
THAT'S THE BOTTOM LINE.
I GO BACK TO THE POINT WHICH IS
I THINK THE MEDIA WAS VERY
COMPLICIT IN THIS BECAUSE THEY
SEIZED UPON IT LIKE A MOUSE WITH
CHEESE.
THEY TRY TO GOBBLE IT UP.
THEIR BIAS TOWARDS
PRESIDENT TRUMP COME AT THE TIME
CANDIDATE TRUMP.
THE MINUTE HE WAS SWORN IN, MORE
CONTINUATION OF RUSSIAN
COLLUSION IN TRUMP TOWER.
THE CAMPAIGN, THE RUSSIANS.
EVERYTHING SHIFTED TO THE NEXT
CHAPTER, DELEGITIMIZE THE
AMERICAN PRESIDENCY WHICH IS OF
COURSE ALSO PLAYING INTO THE
HANDS OF THE RUSSIANS.
THE MEDIA THEN BECAME A PAWN IN
THIS RUSSIAN CHESS.
>> Juan: EMAILS THAT WERE
BEING COVERED WERE HILLARY'S
EMAILS.
>> Greg: I WAS AT THE TABLE,
JUAN, SAYING WE HAD A
RESPONSIBILITY NOT TO COVER
THESE.
>> Juan: BUT TODAY YOU ARE
SAYING THE PRESS WAS A PAWN AND
I AM THINKING THE PRESS,
ESPECIALLY "THE NEW YORK TIMES,"
THEY WERE ALL OVER
HILLARY CLINTON ON THE BASIS OF
THE RUSSIAN --
>> Greg: JESSE IS FALLING
ASLEEP.
>> Jesse: THE AMERICAN MEDIA
GOT DUPED AND THEY UNWITTINGLY
KEYWORD COLLUDED WITH THE
RUSSIANS.
YOU KNOW WHO WITTINGLY COLLUDED?
HILLARY.
YOU KNOW WHO ELSE, ADAM SCHIFF.
TO PUT THIS IN PERSPECTIVE, THIS
RALLY HAD TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE.
THIS WAS AN ANTI-TRUMP SPONSOR
RALLY BY THE RUSSIANS.
THE OTHERS SPONSORED RUSSIAN